but I love okra every time I enter my
home I go to garden first I pick fresh
okra and take it home and my wife knows
how to cook it better than me and she
fries it up and wheat it a girl in
Pakistan was in the garden picking okra
when drawn came and killed her
grandmother parents and 30 other
children she got injured also I'm a
daily life and he defected they have
this anger how they were going to
express that anger towards united state
because United States is 40,000 feet
high or its 10,000 miles away these are
the people who turn into terrorists not
all of them but some of them do so
bombing and killing them will continue
the cycle so the thing is Iraq
Afghanistan Pakistan none of those
countries have suicide bombing before
American occupation and bombing so as a
citizen we need to be confident that
speaking the truth is its duty as an
American citizen as well as its duty as
a Muslim if Muslims are not going to
help with neighbors starting on these
issues who else will when it comes twice
as wicked no my sis not only weaken
demises anytime you know that Orlando
guy who bombed and all that his mustard
people inform FBI here before that the
guy is going nuts FBI didn't do anything
about it because they were probably
looking at some laws that well he's
talking about it not doing anything but
probably I hope they had kept an eye on
it on this guy so Muslims are against
terrorism because we are the number one
victim of war as well as war of terror
as well as terrorism itself